how's it my smile emmanuelle emits he
sometimes wishes he had more endurance
in power oh but this is a surprise the
new Opel Corsa OPC packs a whopping 150
two kilowatts of power fancy taken it
for his spin as he doesn't seem to
bother so it looks pretty nippy but
first time to get dressed for the
occasion OPC stands for the Opel
performance center division set up a
1999 the new Corsa OPC picks up words
predecessor left off the 1.6 liter turbo
gasoline engine brings the fastest
member of the new generation course of
family to 100 km/h in just 6.8 seconds
almost half a second faster than the
previous generation corsa OPC when
accelerating from 80 to 120 km/h and
fifth gear to overtake it's now three
tenths of a second faster eating only
6.4 seconds
yush lining the acceleration of the
course OPC is really fantastic notice
that cause that the course is a
front-wheel drive car which means all
the torque comes through the steered
wheels and so when he accelerates
especially around curves he can really
feel how the engine and all that torque
affect the steering the cause manu-l
finds the Oh pcs cornering ability
incredibly sporty and dynamic there are
several factors at work here so let's
turn to an expert to explain it mascara
Zeppelin opals beyond to hold says a key
development in the new OPC is the fsd
system which means frequency selective
damping control this is an additional
mechanical element that allows the car
suspension to adjust its damping forces
to road conditions I'm passing a tenth
craft in a pinkish cut funding of
Clayton stack Venzon this results in
more grip on fast road sections or
around curves the fsd system is one
hundred percent mechanical and has no
electronic components
ensign and a sporty car like this as
Iman oh well you need plenty of lateral
support and so the Corsa OPC includes
premium recaro seats as standard loving
young you can only navigate the Opel
Corsa with smartphone a map and a route
are shown on the display but there's no
built-in sat-nav it's not even available
as an option the smartphone is connected
to the display via a USB interface the
bring go app then provides the
navigation options on the display inside
the Corsa there are those recaro seats
we mentioned plus numerous OPC logos to
show off this car's motor sports
pedigree
from the outside the OPC stands out in
contrast with the normal corsa thanks to
its front end design large air intakes
and a narrow scoop in front of its
sculpted hood signal the power within
del pecado Manuel says this uncle kors
is sporting through and through but that
athleticism doesn't seem to be rubbing
off on him so he now feels he has some
catching up to do